au théâtre blanche de castille de poissy
collégiens et lycéens partagent leurs
idées avec la députée et florence
granger pour ce grand débat national
spécial jeunes mais aussi avec le
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer présents pour l'occasion
voilà surprise qu'on a eue d'avoir le
ministre de l'éducation c'était vraiment
exceptionnel parce que du coup c'est
vrai qu'on a un peu dévié des grands
thèmes du grand débat national
dans ce grand débat il n'est pas
question d'écologie de fiscalité ou de
pouvoir d'achat pour les 15 20 ans
d'autres questions s'imposent stage à
l'étranger téléphones portables dans les
établissements ou encore cours
d'enseignement moral et civique s'avère
souvent de rattrapages de cours
d'histoire que l'on peut dire
honnêtement
donc voilà c'est dommage une demi-heure
façon nous on est le col et ceux qui
vont être la nouvelle génération qui va
faire la suite de notre pays des jeunes
qui se sentent souvent exclues du grand
débat et qui peine à y participer à la
fin de ces deux heures des échanges d
idées ont pu émerger
certaines ont particulièrement retenu
l'attention de jean michel blanquer r
c'est un moment très agréable parce
qu'on voit les jeunes qui ont envie de
s'engager qui ont aussi beaucoup de
questions à poser
par exemple un qui a proposé une banque
de stages et c'est donc conscient aussi
des tonalités on sent des attentes de la
jeunesse sur certains sujets c'est
important de pouvoir grâce aux grands
débats de bien capter ses idées on a
tout l'avenir devant soi quand on a 15
16 ans et il faut pas s'arrêter au fait
qu'on vive dans un quartier politique de
la ville où le fait qu' on n'est pas
toujours les résultats scolaires adéquat
pour rentrer dans telle ou telle filière
et les jeunes nous ont montré qu'ils
étaient en capacité des croix et c'est
vraiment ce qui m'a le plus marqué
le grand débat national se clôturera le
15 mars